black holes are dense and scary
they suck up everything in their way
their gravity is so strong it bends
light and warps time
but what if I told you we might have
been wrong about these Cosmic vacuum
cleaners
well for one they're not vacuum cleaners
at all
[Music]
ah black holes don't go around gobbling
up everything in their vicinity
you'd have to cross a black hole's Event
Horizon to get sucked into one
The Event Horizon is the area around a
black hole where its gravity is so
strong that you'd have to move at the
speed of light to escape it and moving
that fast is simply impossible at least
according to Einstein that's why there's
no Escape after you cross this line
the extreme gravity would pull you in
and then you disappear into the
Blackness of a black hole forever
forever
[Music]
but as long as you stayed on the safe
side of the Event Horizon you'd be
completely fine
now if you had a bad day and ended up
sucked into a black hole it might not be
as violent as you think
despite a black hole's unimaginably
massive gravity it wouldn't instantly
crush you like a can of soda
no you'd experience something that
scientists call spaghettification
it's when a black hole stretches you
into the shape of well spaghetti if you
were approaching a black hole feet first
your legs would get long and skinny
before your head started to change shape
once you cross the Event Horizon the
stretching you'd experience would be
extreme and painful the black hole
wouldn't Crush you instead it would rip
your molecules apart
this whole spaghettification process
would only take a few seconds maybe a
few minutes tops sorry did I say it
wouldn't be violent
yeah I take that back this would really
hurt
but the good news is you could still
make a comeback
just not in the same form as you entered
the black hole
yeah you may have heard that nothing
escapes a black hole but that isn't
exactly true
all thanks to Hawking radiation
turns out black holes have an
interesting Quantum phenomenon going on
at the very edge of a black hole's Event
Horizon particles are constantly forming
some of them fall back into the black
hole but others escape this
monstrosity's gravity in the form of
radiation
Hawking radiation to be specific
over time so many particles escape a
black hole's Event Horizon that the
black hole disappears entirely
like it never even existed
but it takes an incredibly long time for
a black hole to evaporate like this
and unfortunately you wouldn't be able
to reassemble yourself from all those
emitted particles
so I really wouldn't recommend jumping
into a black hole especially not into a
super massive black hole in the middle
of our galaxy
one good thing that can come from
getting close to a black hole is that
you could hypothetically Harvest its
radiation and use it to power things
back on Earth
of course we're nowhere near that kind
of Technology but we have other sources
to produce clean renewable energy like
nuclear fission
I know when you think of green energy
all that comes to mind is solar panels
and wind turbines well that's why I
wanted to tell you about nuclear energy
it's zero emission meaning it doesn't
generate harmful byproducts like fossil
fuels it uses way less land than solar
or wind farms to produce massive amounts
of carbon-free power and it's super
efficient when it comes to waste
win-win-win as we aim for a cleaner
future nuclear energy can massively help
us reach the goal of 100 clean
electricity by 2035 and a net zero
emissions economy by 2050. now that
sounds like the kind of future I'd be
looking forward to you
well at least it's a lot better than
falling into a black hole
you see there are different types of
black holes the most common ones are
Stellar black holes
they are the remnants of stars at least
20 times more massive than our sun
and because they're so dense well their
event Horizons can be several kilometers
in diameter
super massive black holes are monstrous
unimaginably big
the most massive black hole scientists
have spotted so far is located in the
middle of Phoenix a Galaxy
it's got a mass of 100 billion Suns
yeah billion with a B
at this point it's not just a super
massive black hole
it's a stupendously large black hole or
slab
until recently scientists thought the
biggest supermassive giant was ton 618.
a black hole with 66 billion solar
masses
but there's so much of the cosmos we
haven't discovered yet and
maybe supermassive black holes can be
much much more massive than we could
ever imagine
scientists still don't know exactly how
these Cosmic monstrosities formed and
we've got no idea what happens when two
of them Collide but it sure wouldn't be
pretty for anything caught in between
them
but at least we can still observe them
to find out more
a black hole's gravity is so intense
that even light can't escape it but that
doesn't mean they're the stealthy ninjas
of the cosmos
they're very much visible just not in
the way you might think
because their gravitational pull affects
Stars around them astronomers can detect
their gravitational effects
they can also see x-rays when something
big falls into a black hole
that's because when matter is pulled to
the point of no return it heats up to
intense temperatures
but the most mysterious thing about
black holes is
what lies on the other side
there are theories that black holes can
be gateways to other universes
a black hole might be connected to
another point in space and time through
what's known as an Einstein Rosen Bridge
it's a type of Wormhole and a very
unstable one
now scientists haven't found proof of
that yet but that doesn't mean it's not
possible
what if we could use black holes as
Cosmic Subways where could they take us
could it be another reality
another time
well while all of this is fun to think
about there's one big problem
Einstein rosenbridges are incredibly
unstable
they could collapse on you at any moment
trapping you inside a black hole before
you could reach your mysterious
destination
and even if we were lucky enough to pass
through that bridge before it collapsed
there's still no way you could survive
it the intense gravity and radiation
would likely destroy you long before you
popped out on the other side
maybe one day we'll learn to travel
through black holes but for now it's
best to stick to exploring our own solar
system
hey why not visit Titan one of Saturn's
most beautiful moons
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
foreign